as the country looks forward to the
covered crisis hopefully easing
in the coming months the dangers for the
chancellor will only increase
in many ways managing the economic
recovery is the moment of maximum danger
for risky sunnah something he's probably
well aware of
as he prepares for his second budget on
wednesday and i'm pleased to say the
chancellor
joins us now thank you very much for
being here with us um
i'm keen to talk about the budget of
course um but just firstly
on the roadmap that we saw which feels
like the the way out for the economy as
well as
of the pandemic and i understand of
course you say that it's going to be
driven by data
not dates so does that mean if the data
is better than expected
that roadmap could happen quicker than
you've laid out
well what the prime minister laid out
was a series of steps
with appropriate gaps between them for
us to understand the impact of each step
and as he said what we want is a
cautious but irreversible
approach that's why we've taken the
approach
that we have and those will be the
earliest dates that we think we can do
the various things that we've we've laid
out but we're doing everything we can to
make sure that it is hopefully
irreversible that's what we want to see
what i understand is if you say it's
driven by data and not dates but you say
it can only move in one direction
and it could only slow down but it can't
speed up then it doesn't really feel
like it is driven by data it feels like
it's driven by dates
well it's it wants to be cautious right
because i think what we want and as you
talked about businesses before in your
opening what businesses don't want is a
stop-start
approach to this we want to know that
it's a one-way road
and that's why it's cautious we've given
the earliest of dates
to give a sense of timing and a sense of
direction
and then obviously we might have to
adjust those if things are not going
exactly as we would like but the
early signs are promising we're seeing
great news with the rollout of the
vaccine
not just the take up of it but also the
efficacy of the vaccine the data that
we're getting is showing us that it is
working
so i think that should give us all a
sense of confidence and optimism about
the future
that we can make progress on that
roadmap and as you said hopefully slowly
get our lives back to normal i'm sure so
many businesses are going to be hoping
to feel that confidence and optimism but
of course it's been a really difficult
time for
so many different businesses across the
uk you're announcing a new grant scheme
just tell us a bit more about what the
idea is yeah well we know that
particularly businesses in the
hospitality leisure accommodation and
retail have been
affected by the restrictions and they're
still closed
uh in the coming weeks and will only
open slowly and still with some
restrictions
we want to support them as they reopen
want to support them to keep staff to
pay bills
and that's why we're launching the
restart grants which we paid
in april worth 5 billion pounds in total
but up to
18 000 pounds for a particular
hospitality business on the larger side
and those will be paid through local
authorities to over 650
000 business properties across the
country to help them as we reopen and
get our economy going again
a lot of the businesses um who can be
affected by this are high street firms
are you worried about the long-term
consequences of the fact everyone's been
shopping more online during the pandemic
and is this something that you might be
looking at to try and help the high
street and perhaps
looking at targeting some of those
online companies well that's why we've
put in place this
this grant scheme the restart grants
because businesses that have been forced
to close
multiple times over the past year
actually employ millions of people and
what i care about is protecting as many
jobs
as possible by supporting those
businesses to protect those jobs that's
what this grant will they've been hit in
a way that online firms haven't been
frankly
and that's why we we've put something in
place previously called the digital
services tax which i announced at last
year's budget
which is a tax on online marketplaces
and we're working with our international
colleagues actually this year
and i'm doing that through the g7 and
the g20 group of finance ministers
to find an international agreement on
taxing digital companies
but look our high streets are really
important that's why we have the high
streets and towns fund that's why we've
done planning reforms
that's why we're now providing generous
cash grants to help those businesses get
back on their feet keep their staff
as we reopen in the coming weeks and
months okay now when i announced you're
gonna be on the show today i was
inundated with questions from people and
one of them
is from andy now he says i work at
manchester airport the aviation industry
has been badly affected by covid
will the furlough scheme last for a
while longer student of course to finish
in april but the restrictions are not
going to lift all the restrictions
until june well when it comes to support
in general
i said at the beginning of this crisis
that i would do whatever it took to
protect people families and businesses
through this crisis
and i remain completely committed to
that the prime minister
in in the road map set out a path for us
to recover and reopen
and i want to support people and
businesses along that path
it's going to be extensive i'm not going
to comment on specific policies but i
want to make sure people realize that
you know we are going to be there to
support them and if you look at our
track record
we went big we went early and there's
more to come next week with regard to
airports for example
they had a generous break on their
business rates over this past year
that furlough scheme i know has been
helpful for many people employed in that
industry i know how difficult
it is and i want them to have the
reassurance that we are here to keep
supporting people
as we reopen the economy but andy wants
specific reassurance
on the furlough scheme well wednesday is
budget when we'll set out the next step
of everything but andy and others
you know hopefully will have had
reassurance over the past year knowing
that we've done
absolutely everything we can to support
businesses families and people through
this crisis
and we remain as you can see by today's
announcement uh supporting our high
street businesses committed to that goal
once restrictions are eased is that
going to be the time to start winding up
some of the support packages you're
talking about
well i think it's right that the support
aligns with the roadmap so the prime
minister's roadmap has a path on which
we will
slowly reopen our economy and we want to
make sure that our support
supports people along that path and
that's what you will see on wednesday
and we've been doing this for a while
our support has been adapting and
evolving
remember back in july last year i set
out our plan for jobs
that's because protecting and supporting
creating jobs is my number one economic
priority
tragically three-quarters of a million
people have already lost their jobs
i want to make sure that all of those
people have fresh hope and opportunity
so this weekend we also announced that
we are doubling the
bonus that we provide to companies to
hire new apprentices for example up to 3
000 pounds
for apprentices of any age it's an
example of us continuing to
adapt and evolve policy to support
people into work
and one more question this is from
petrina she wants to know are you going
to be removing the 20 pound a week
increase in universal credit
yeah again katrina budget on wednesday
is a there's a place where we'll set out
all of our
next stages of our response but i know
that that uplift has
has made a difference to people over the
past uh past 12 months it's you know one
part of a comprehensive plan that we've
put in place to protect people
you know particularly those on low
incomes and looking forward
we can point to the fact that we're
increasing the national living wage next
year by above inflation which will mean
almost a 350 pound pay rise
for someone working full-time you've
said you touched on the difference it
makes people they would it not be unfair
to remove that uplift if you as you call
it before
the restrictions end as i said the prime
minister's road map
sets out of path and we want to support
people along that path and
people will see that on on wednesday
whether it's with the national living
wage increase
support with new apprenticeships whether
it's support for businesses it will
remain committed to supporting
businesses families
and people through this crisis now you
say you want to
support people through the crisis of
course that comes at a cost uk
debt now around two trillion pounds how
worried are you
well we've just been talking about the
support that we've put and put in place
as a result of chronovirus but
chronovirus has also just had an
enormous
toll on our economy and i want to level
with people
about that about the problem that causes
and the challenges that it presents us
with
and be honest about our plan to address
those okay
um i mean some would argue that you know
interest rates are low we should be
relaxed about borrowing money because we
can do so
cheaply at the minute i mean to look at
joe biden for example in the us
with this big stimulus package that he's
announced is that a
view that you subscribe to well we've
gone to stimulus again just worth
bearing on we've spent almost 300
billion pounds over the past 12 months
supporting people
so we we are doing that and we will keep
doing that but we've got
yeah we've got we've got regard to the
future as you said i think it look it's
we do have a challenge in our public
finances and if if we don't do anything
borrowing will continue to be at very
high levels even after we've recovered
from covert debt will continue to rise
indefinitely and that's not a good
situation for a couple of reasons
i mean firstly if you think about how
i've been able to respond during this
crisis
i think generously and boldly and
comprehensively that was only possible
because we entered the crisis
with strong public finances i want to
make sure when the next shock
comes along whoever's sitting here can
do the same thing that i've done
they need strong public finances to do
that that's austerity then
secondly you talked about interest rates
and you're right interest rates you know
have been at very low levels
uh which does allow us to afford
slightly higher debt levels but that can
always change and we're seeing that in
the last few weeks
people will know about that when they
think about their own mortgages for
example
you know when interest rates change what
can i afford so we have to be acute
to that possibility and thirdly we also
want to deliver on our
commitments to deliver strong public
services and i want to be able to do
that as well so for all those reasons
you know making sure that we have strong
public finances is important
that's why i want to level with people
about the challenges and set out our
plan to address that you mentioned the
risk of increasing interest rates are
you worried then like in the summer
there's a lot of pent-up savings for
example
interest rates could actually rise and
have a serious impact on the public
finances
well in terms of you're right there are
pent-up savings and as we saw
last year as the economy reopened
we saw that spending come back which is
great and we want people out and about
that will help drive our recovery
i think the other thing that i'm i'm
keeping an eye on there was also
business investment
that has taken a toll over the past 12
months and we want to see business
investment also playing its part in
driving our recovery
and you can rest assured that we'll be
looking at every possible way to support
our economic recovery
so at what point then do you start
looking
at trying to bring some of that debt
down this budget
this year at what point well i i think
there are two things one is we want to
keep supporting the economy right
because of the restrictions are still in
place
there's a road map over which they will
lift and we'll provide support for
people along
uh that path and i remain committed to
that whether it's with apprenticeship
bonuses support for high streets as
we've seen today or the various other
things that we're doing
we announced the creation of a new
national infrastructure bank as well
this weekend which will help drive our
recovery but it's important for the
reasons we talked about to also
have strong public finances over time
that this is not something that's going
to happen overnight
given the scale of the shock we've
experienced the scale of the damage
this is going to take time to but when
does it when does it start though
because i
i know obviously it's not going to start
before june you've been very clear about
supporting people until that roadmap
ends but
should we be expecting for you to be
focusing on rebalancing of those public
finances
in the near term in this year well i
think what what you want and what i want
to deliver is support for our economy
now when it needs it support along that
road map helping to drive our recovery
but also leveling with people and being
straight about the challenges we face
over time because of the shock
coronavirus has caused our public
finances and making sure that we're
clear with people about
an honest and fair plan to address that
and i think those things are both
compatible okay well let's talk about
the honest and fair plan to address that
a lot of people
will be saying that one way to address
that is through tax rises we currently
have the lowest levels of
corporation tax in the g7 19
are we still going to have the lowest
amount of corporation tax by the end of
this parliament
yeah sophie unfortunately it's difficult
for me to talk about specific
tax policy and specific taxes i know
it's frustrating for you it'll be
frustrating for your
viewers but the simple reason for that
is taxes obviously have an impact on
businesses and on market
and it's not appropriate for a
chancellor to talk about those outside
of a bike could it rise though
again it's not i can't talk about
specific tax policies it's
unfortunate but appropriate that we we
leave that for budget so i apologize for
that well let's in that case talk about
your last manifesto then because in your
last manifesto
you said this we will not raise not this
this is the tax rate so we will not
raise the rate of
income tax vat or national insurance
that was
the election manifesto that you stood on
are you going to stick to that promise
again you're you're asking me to talk
about specific tax policy and
unfortunately i'm asking if you're going
to break an election promise it's a bit
different isn't it no well we're just
we're a couple of days in advance of a
budget and again tax policy is
appropriately dealt with that at the
budget
um okay um are you considering
some people there's reports on papers
today that you're considering freezing
the amount at which people start paying
the basic rate of income tax and the
higher rate of income tax now that
wouldn't be breaking the pledge
but it would be stretching the pledge
wouldn't it look i think
look again i can't i it's really
difficult for me to talk about specific
tax policy for the reasons that i've
i've explained but taking a step back
you know this is about as i said
appreciating the damage that chronovirus
has done to our economy
recognizing the scale of the support
that we've put in place
ensuring that we protect the economy
through the rest of the crisis support
people and businesses as we emerge
through
the road map but also making sure that
our public finances over time are
returned to a strong position
so that we can respond to the next
crisis so that we're protected as
interest rates may or may not
change and that we can deliver strong
public services
that's what that's what we're going to
do and as as conservatives
i think people elect us to deliver those
things and and i think that's important
i understand you don't want to talk
about specifics ahead of a budget
but you know you've been chanted for a
year you've been firefighting mo that
whole time with a pandemic i'm just
trying to get a sense of what
you actually are as a chancellor what
the vision is you know are you
you know a low tax chancellor do you
want to cut
taxes to help the recovery to increase
investment are you someone who wants to
see a stimulus like joe biden
are you someone who wants to increase
taxes because you've got an eye on the
state of the public finances you know
what what is the sort of rishi's tsunami
vision
well i'm a conservative and i believe in
in lower taxes
look what's happened to us over the past
12 months we've faced a shock
unlike that which we've ever seen before
and it required
a very particular response from
government it required government and me
to do things that i never imagined i
would have to do that no government
would probably imagine they have to do
but i think i believe that was the right
thing to do
you know i stood up and said i would do
whatever it takes to protect people and
businesses through this crisis
i meant it and that's what we've
delivered over the past 12 months an
unprecedented amount of support
for families and the economy at a very
difficult time i mean to keep doing that
and deliver on the things that we were
elected to do whether that's 50 000 more
nurses 20 000 more police officers 40
new hospitals
to invest in infrastructure all around
the country to level up opportunity
those are the things people elected us
to do and they elected us to be
responsible with their money and that's
what i plan to deliver
you say you believe in low taxes now
according to the sunday times you told
mps last week
that you want to plug the 43 billion
black hole
so you can cut taxes in a pre-election
budget i mean that sounds an awful lot
like playing politics with the recovery
did you say that
no i think in terms of specific numbers
i think it it it's a bit hard for anyone
to be precise about specific numbers
did you say that to them no i don't
recognize that that figure actually
the being specific so specific with
numbers at this stage when there's so
much economic uncertainty i i don't
think
actually anyone could uh could do that
that wouldn't be the
that wouldn't okay so you don't
recognize the figure but did you tell
mps last week
that you want to cut taxes in a
pre-election budget i i
i would like to be able to keep taxes
low for people in general that i'm a
conservative and i believe in that
but i want to deliver our promises that
we
made to the british people that we would
be responsible with their money that we
would look after the nation's finances
and we would deliver strong public
services and given
the shock that coronavirus has caused us
i think it's right for me to have acted
in the way that i have provide the
support that we are providing and will
continue to provide it sounds like
it sounds like you did say this that you
would you know try and rebalance the
the finances in the short term so you
could cut taxes for a pre-election
budget i think it sounds like you did i
think in the short term what we need to
do is
protect the economy and keep supporting
the economy through the road map
and over time what we need to do is is
make sure that our public finances are
sustainable and that's what we've been
talking about that leveling with people
about what that's going to require that
that isn't going to happen overnight
that is going to be
work that takes time given the scale of
the shock
that we've experienced but if you're
asking me you know
do i want to deliver low taxes for
people of course i do
um the difficulty of course in some ways
is going to be not the the moment at
this time when you've got the highest
approval ratings in in cabinet you're
giving money away you're trying to
support people through the pandemic
but it's going to be the rebalancing are
you worried that once you have to start
taking money off people then you know no
amount of those slick instagram posts
are going to keep those approval ratings
up
you know i'm not worried about that
right what i'm worried about is just
trying to do the right thing at the
right time
and be honest and straight with people
about what we're doing and why we're
doing it and hopefully do things in a
way that's fair
and commands broad support that that's
what you'll see on wednesday and that's
what i've tried to do throughout this
crisis
talking about your sort of your
throughout the crisis as i said you know
you're the most popular person
in cabinet according to the polls but
you know when it comes to covert some
would argue
you've got quite a lot of things wrong
you've been on the wrong side of the
argument
according to the university of warwick
your eat out to help out scheme caused
a significant rise in new infections and
accelerated the pandemic into its second
wave
last september you said that we must
learn to live with it live without fear
and according to the oms in september
what 18 000 people more than 80 000
people have died with covered on their
death certificate have you got some
things wrong
well with regard to eat out to help out
actually i think there's there's many
different studies and
i don't agree with that because if you
look at it actually
areas where eat out help out was used
the most for example in the southwest
were the slowest to see any rise in
infections and actually had very low
infection rates
and almost all other major countries
have had rises
over the autumn and winter and they
didn't have eat out to help out so i
think it's a bit odd to
ascribe uh causality in that way and
what i was trying to do
and i think is the right thing to do is
try and protect the over two million
people that work in the hospitality
industry
they're often lower-paid younger women i
think as a matter of social justice
those jobs are really important for us
to try and protect and that's why
today we're announcing five billion
pounds of grants to help those
businesses
keep those jobs that will always be very
important to me
and as we look to the future we will
have to learn to live with coronavirus
vaccines we're going to roll them out
and and we will have a very
successful rollout of them and they are
proving to be really effective which is
fantastic
you know but no vaccine is perfect and
in the same way that we live with flu
you know we will have to learn to live
with chronovirus that's something that
i think doctors would agree with it will
become something that we learn to live
with like flu so i think that is
actually
the right way to approach it um just
finally well i've got you i just want to
ask you about
shimmy and bagan and she left the uk of
course to join islamic state when she
was a school girl
the supreme court recently ruled she
can't return to the uk to fight that
decision to strip her of her citizenship
now i don't want to talk about the
rights and wrongs
of her case if she should be a citizen
or not but you know her
the government was able to take away her
citizenship because her parents were
born
abroad that they were born in a
different country so someone whose
parents have been born in this country
had done exactly the same thing as
shamim bagan she wouldn't have been
treated
in the same way is that fair are you
comfortable with that well i think i'm
glad that the supreme court has made
a made decision that they have and i
think they've they've opined on the
matter and that's probably the right way
for it to be but do you comfortable the
fact that she would be treated
differently if her parents hadn't been
born abroad well i think the supreme
court decision supported what the
government
was trying to do and i'm glad that it
has and i think that's the right
decision in this case that we've been
able to reach